other hand
ni for
so here
enter
turn that same side from the same
direction you can rock our I one I still
have to enter and I still have to 10 con
she goes that way I go this way in turn
other side is
alive 10 she goes that way I step out
and enter as she comes
around
enter 10 come she goes this way I step
out enter she comes around
okay try
all right you have to think about it a
little bit okay so if we're just
here I don't want my angle of
deflection to move with my angle of
deviation okay I'm trapping myself in
this thing
okay so my angle of if my angle of
deviation is going to my
left then the angle of the flexion has
to go to my right you see
that so that's the rule we're working on
here so one two she's going to go this
way and I go this way that's the
move what you're confused
with is you want to be
homolateral so you go here and you go
step to the right move to the left you
want your body in there it's not like
that one two turn she goes this
way this way she goes
okay just try that part is right before
we go under the so if we look and here
we have a grid pattern okay so right
when she grabs you can see that we're on
the same line okay uh she's pushing at
me okay and I am standing right right in
front of her what I'm going to do is
transform this relationship between in
these spirals okay if you pay attention
in normal iido someone's going to go
over
here and then go like this okay but
we're still on a 126 line okay do you
see that right and then they bring them
around and on on the 126 line again and
then they go out and then they come
around
okay so again
look 126
line 126 lines you see and it come
around I didn't do anything
okay so what we're going to do is change
the we're going to get rid of the
126 okay and I do that by start
rotating this thing
okay and as we start to go
I don't want to go on
126 I'm going to keep her moving you see
and we are now on the 39 line but I'm
not really on the 39 line you see cuz I
didn't go to here so I kept turning her
and now I do my ten con you see and I'm
on that 39 line again on the other side
now okay
she's going to come
around and I'm over
here okay like this so if we look at her
and me I'm going to start
using the 48 line when I
enter she's now on the 28 line you see
so if you look here this has already
changed got it
so when she passes me now she comes
around what I'm going to do is I have
built a
relationship on the
hand i'm centered on the hand I'm not on
her line stay there
please I'm not over here trying to get
under the
arm I'm over
here centered on the hand okay she's
going around and so I do my movement to
keep her on that line and now I've
entered and I'm on the 82 line so think
about how I went from the 126 line and I
started hitting the diagonals okay so I
don't ever want to
go then do that I'm trying to root rot
take this whole thing
around
[Music]
okay and as long as I understand that
then what I've been saying is going to
make sense okay she's going to go past
me and I turn this because I can because
I'm under the hand not in front
boom boom boom and I'm
in okay never coming around and I'm in
front of her time to go
out you pay attention if I wish we had a
camera from the
top incrementally and
incrementally I move from being in front
of her see to being behind her you see
on a spiral and I keep back here till
she passes me and I turn the other
way
[Music]
okay okay try it again
is uh come to this side please here we
go go
[Music]
here okay watch see where I'm out here
now see and don't just try to lift this
up push down you see even as much as
she's at a disadvantage do you see and I
can get my spine under here I don't want
to I want to keep her going the way she
she's going you see so we have to pay
attention
to how to get from
here to
here
see so
you're you're here like this okay what
you're going to do is get zero pressure
here that means I don't push in you that
means I don't pull you okay where it
goes and see her elbow I Chang the
relationship of her elbow it's on
top
okay don't just take this
hand and
pull down you're going to stop her try
to go forward you see and I want her to
pass me you a lot of people just go like
this and then the UK lets them lift it
up
but more importantly the UK stop moving
because they can't move okay so I'm
going to take that
elbow and reverse it w right there I I
go underneath that
okay so
[Music]
one two look at her
elbow I move to keep that elbow
Mo I'm exagerating it
now common way
incorrect see I did all work cuz he's
letting me do it I can feel the deltoid
we only have the Inward and the outward
spiral so that's what I use okay at the
beginning it's the outward spiral but
because I'm turning inward it
accomplishes it with the inward spiral
does you see then I go to the inward
spiral okay let's
try
e
e e
so let's I'm
doing okay so I'm going to do eel right
and we know that her arm goes in there's
that elbow Bend you see and then I am
going to just turn the
elbow over the top you see it's the same
exact movement okay if you watch my
hand you go you're going to do get
on see get on and you cannot undo
it you didn't pass the chew on and this
mve does not exist in
Iko so let's camera over
[Music]
here there's gon you see and I have to
do you're going to watch my hand forget
her elbow and I have to do Cheon it's
right there you see and then it keeps
turning and there's your iners
spiral now I can't go here here where
was the Chon there was no Chon then that
does not exist in iudo okay so again I'm
in
gon I go to Chon there it is and then it
passes
over okay now if you watch I'm going to
do that same thing and you watch her
elbow and all I'm doing with her elbow
is taking it here keeping it in that
same angle and turning it
there so you wash your elbow and her
elbow just rotates around it you
see again her elbow just turns elbow up
was elbow down and it goes elbow up
without expanding the arm now watch me
do the other one get
on I skip chew on what happened to the
Elbow do you see it's not there and then
that's crazy cannot do that okay so you
have to have a chew on in here as you're
coming
around is chew on right there chew on
right
here right
there okay try it
again for